hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video i'm going to
talk about chabot stick sign so let's
get started chavats excite is a specific
type of facial muscle twitching that
occurs when cranial nerve 7 the facial
nerve is manually stimulated and this
demonstrates hyperexcitability of the
facial nerve it tends to be associated
with patients who are experiencing
hypocalcemia so a low level of calcium
in the blood because many times these
patients are experiencing irritability
of their nerves and muscles it can also
be seen in patients who have a low
magnesium level so how do we assess for
tavat six time well we're looking for
either a positive sign or a negative
sign positive means they have it
negative means they do not so first you
want to identify the location of the
masseter muscle on the patient which is
located at the jaw's angle next you want
to tap on this muscle and assess the
response of the facial muscles on the
side that was manually tapped if it's
positive the facial muscles will
contract momentarily example the lips
will twitch if it's negative no changes
will occur okay so that wraps up this
review over chavat stick sign and if
you'd like to watch more review lectures
you can access the link in the youtube
description below